so I'm late joining the eastern blitz
arena and it tied for actually in clear
last place but okay it's a 90-minute
long tournament it started can I do math
about 17 minutes ago so a small
disadvantage but I think the goal is to
try and win and I'll beserk when I can
hello to people I'll be chess first in
the chat yeah I'm gonna play
aggressively
hey it's tigey welcome back tog II Leon
Dyke welcome back Park HP and J moolah
back a pact with III I play d5 it's off
on line that move I'll play this move so
kind of have a typical grand Grand Prix
our leopard thanks for subbing and
Oilers swimming for five months and four
months respectively I respect that
let's play this move hello yeah hello
toilers lice Amir welcome back bones
playing well for the rating like doing
all the kind of main English ideas
usually white wants to play some like
Queen side pawn storm in the structure
before before might be a mistake
so blocks of Bishop it does reinforce
the Knights but someday in the future
I'll play c6 I found here is Bishop g4
94 c6 Kingson gifting a sub - zero eight
one five asdf what does asdf stand for
should be an acronym for it right
thank you Kingston okay let's take I
need tips for playing the Danish gambit
um be careful who you play against it's
not about opening I'd say against anyone
below like 1700 okay stuff
there's a lot to happen in f3 coming f3
it's gonna fork but ok that was nice 16
moves stream bits those are that's a
pretty generic bits thanks taggi stream
bits is an anagram of master bits anyway
uh London time
maybe Java London time okay this will be
some Puetz ooh
I'll try and mix up the opening us but
in general I'm gonna try and play
aggressively I forgot to Mazurek I
always play off three always play king
be one let's take a pawn the D pawn is
pinned mmm let's take another pawn I
think I'm just up two pawns here and
Queenie five expected play Bishop c4
discouraging Bishop e6 play this move
hmm I do have time to think the the
tournament time is ticking Oh point 92 I
might just want to play solid like King
bee one night c1 eventually Knight b3
Bishop g5 looks very attractive Oh
Bishop g5 aims at Bishop because Queens
move sideways hmm looking at f7 94 is
interesting play 94 of takes takes
blocks and some dilemma as those pieces
are kind of hanging now I might be three
attempting to trap the Queen Queen as
that's square okay I'll just take and
win another pond
I feel like Yasser it's a nice feeling
about three pawns always play King me
one now I feel like been flying gold
okay life is so good because if the rook
moves I win the bishop and the pawn
hangs I'll play this move next nice
alignment asking for a rook c8 rook c8
maybe Bishop takes first
okay just resigns that was nice so first
game with 16 moves out with 21 moves
hello to more people it pits eraser if
Krishna yeah nice to see some familiar
faces I'm doing well
oh wait let's preserve yeah I'll play
you for this game let's play it Maura
hmm I play here play the smoke okay
trying to yeah achieve tomorrow night
have sex I have this that move I think
the general plan is to pressure the d6
pawn I'm actually not so booked up I
mean this looks like a move morning
blitz bits morning blitz blitz it's okay
I give up
it's too difficult giving up after two
tries wait 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 ok I can count
it's a miracle
oh this move but then my bishop hangs ok
something should work here in Bishop G 3
is no Bishop d7 is coming so I have to
do something immediate maybe this amount
of the rooks trapped
if takes I trap the Queen with my pawn
that's so beautiful oh that's a move
let's take yeah coz after it takes I'm
turning this so if this is if this is I
meet and if this this this I take here
and when the rook
okay so alive 30 seconds left but I'll
be up a good amount of material take a
pollen defender pond
take another pollen again I feel like
yeah sir expecting nexi for ya I just
wanna go in for the kill I should make
Luffy at some point that's a free night
rook defends mate let's play rook d7
making loops check the plans okay now
it's just about meeting there we go
okay John welcome back 144th that's
twelve twelve square weights
twelve times twelve thanks John for
joining yet again orach welcome back
orange orange get to see people dubious
chess let's play dubious chess against
Julius chess maybe yeah dubious chest
I'm not sure whether I'm gonna have fun
or okay I'll have fun Mike fell for
probably one of the most common Stafford
gambit traps only move here is Bishop
III and then I'll take with the night
dark sort bishops very happy Queen g5
the team is stuck bishop controls both
of the casting destinations eric is
confused wait why
I mean the world is a confusing place
it's hard to live without being confused
sometimes that's a move a Bishop d2 I
think I'll play Bishop to d4 first g5
Queen d6 we already have a Johnny Mons
the GM John Davis emotes it's been
around for a while I have a new emo to
that is not getting enough use which
people can find and if you're watching
on in the future on YouTube you'll have
to follow on twitch to find the emotes
ok what to do
that's slightly annoying move I could
take do I dare take the pawn I guess mmm
it might be dubious but that's my goal
this game anyway if this and this and
we'll have some fun hey you guys found
it oh it's weird watching me live
because you're used to watching me in
the future right oh you're on lunch
break lunch break and just past midnight
what oh no that sounded slightly wrong
oh let's play wait
what to do I thought it almost worked
but it's tricky
hmm time is ticking Chuck Chuck
let's start with this one the Tobin
material so play Bishop b6 both Kings
are looking slightly slightly attackable
that's the right word gari what's up
welcome darling shout out to gari I can
spell that right my bad for the
misspelling okay Bishop a5 is an idea I
mean this this would be a defending and
attacking move
so yeah let's do it the Kings still kind
of suffering but this I'm gonna save the
bishop guess the Queen the Queen and
Bishop are a bit quarantined
that's my queen bee to Nicola welcome
back shout out to Nicola s own Nicola
storage sin
thanks for the bits well I'm attacking
the pawn oh I'm okay time is gonna be
very relevant played Bishop a5 just want
to remove the rook and win the pawn and
then in this pawn move this pawn so I'm
defending a7 now yeah again I feel like
you're taking so many pawns it's been
the knight attack the knight
keep you so safe push some pawns of t3
incoming I won the rook and another pawn
yasser would be so proud
it's hard to me Gossard prouder okay I
have five seconds left check check okay
almost flag there man
oh what the game was a weird game so I'm
catching up i late join the tournaments
I'm in 13th place with 15 tournament
points first place has 21 okay
let's avoid buzzer King but I'll still
try and play aggressively it's hard to
play aggressive against this setup so
I'll play I'll play a line with beef oh
I can't play b5 I can't play this line I
think this is one of the most aggressive
lines so it involves an exchange sack if
white plays this there's Queen takes d4
takes and then takes and still 95 takes
t4 that's a move yeah so I think I just
have to give back the pawn and complete
development
I don't play a5 preventing 95
there's my t5 here hitting the bishop
it's a tense position he forced coming
have to allow it
ooh let's not play Knight b6 what to do
I want to play c5 usually if you can
play c5 and get away with it
it's a minute to play idea rook c8 and
there's enough support
even if takes takes it's getting
complicated
I mean that f6 looks natural now if
takes I could take with Knights the
pawns attack I don't take with night
here expecting or up team one those
pawns also attack though b3 ideas Queen
c7 Bishop f4
it's a confusing position in b3 I can't
play queen c8 I have an idea I'm gonna
play Queen yeat attack the pawn like
that except theirs might be six ideas
that's getting really weird I had to get
off the file the rook so I'm attacking
both of these pawns and the Knights
attacking the pawn - these pawns are are
weird because they're not nothing's
defending each other okay so if I take
Knight b6 and I take for the night it
doesn't feel right but let's do it
this is kind of expected the Queen d5
I'm just trying to control squares and
Bishop f1 maybe Queen before but then
Bishop d2 d2 Queen c5 it's just a mess
oh I have this threat to all I could
have taken should have taken an IC 5
here and Bishop d2 might be coming never
mind
so I'm up a pawn I also have the dark
squared Bishop which is a great piece in
this position play rook to e8 White's
trying to attack h6 would have been
uncomfortable ooh
I'll play Bishop d4 and there's a lot of
pressure against the pawn White has
three defenders now four defenders okay
let's push the a pawn down a bit of time
this one's kind of hanging the officer
would be disappointed in me
if I take there's no need to take takes
takes just increase pressure I could
have still taken the pawn but there's
more important things to do in life like
not flag okay I'll take the pawn yeah I
move back yeah the file is open
doesn't confuse what to do here okay
I'll take care of takes I I Fork the
king and queen Wow okay that's nice
check a pin and then f6 band okay
take another pawn let's just go for meat
that's so nice meat pieces the white
piece has helped out okay that was
probably the most difficult game so far
yeah there's a hard position to
understand
I'm very tactical let's play a London
stick with my my bread and butter
I stocked up on on bread and butter
today also say hi to taggi what does
this move might be three also say hi to
like everyone in the twitch tent even
though you're the same people sometimes
ok so I just want to develop everything
was defended I think it's a little bit
kind of uncomfortable my Queens tied
that to the night but everything else is
okay but what to do let's play in this
move idea Bishop d3 even 93 93
kind of just doing nothing waiting to
figure out what to do I'm keeping some
time advantage maybe I have three ideas
long-term like f3 Knight f2 then II for
night off for maybe I'll win the bishop
pair played Bishop d3 f3 for I can't win
the bishop here I could play g4 I'll
start with Bishop d3
I still want to play f3 I can't take
Ivy 1404 doesn't work wanted to take but
she takes maybe g4 also take and plate
positionally hmm that's a critical
moment
I wasn't sure what to do
okay now I can take maybe f4 coming
we're got to the e5 is coming I should
prevent you five okay some kind of
potential pawn storm yeah I want to move
the night away like to a better square
just have to defend me to maybe rook b1
it looks slow but okay 92 coming a 96
expected and then some idea to push the
pawn now like him G 3 rock H 1 H 5 yes
c4 I just retreats f5 might be possible
f5 g5 it seems weird but my king is
still sheltered idea of this and this
there's 94 I probably take with Bishop I
still want to play this interesting guy
have to go into this and keep the
tension yeah I want to play another
three Wow hmm I should play g6 I mean
well I could also just take takes g6
mm-hmm I play g6 takes 95 yeah let's go
for that or 95 or 95 ideas
I'll have the g5 square as an outposts I
mean black has this annoying move but
then 9 g5 traps are king kind of oh not
that six I played 95 and fork
[Music]
yes now the kings of it stuck that's a
good move
confusing position again I think I just
want to triple up against the H pawn B
oh this one was hanging I forgot to
channel my inner Yasser hmm that's gonna
be a time scramble my threatening to
take not sure rook e1 I guess you can't
do that let's play rook c1 untangling
before ideas and now the Queen's tied
down to B 5 H 5 is a bit more weak this
move I shifted completely blockade the
pawn yeah locks just about to flag
wow that's still very complicated
position the black took a little bit too
much time ignore him he'll dirty flag
irregardless
that's a nice and my sentence slightly
dirty sentence
hey we have a GN gory fan shout out yeah
so if you're just joining I'm playing
the super blitz arena trying to win it
trying to play aggressively g3 let's
play h5 so this is a way to be
aggressive
lady five idea the idea h3 attack the
bishop I want to play e5 soon
now I'm 34 to trap the bishop Wow
oh it's not a trap yet like a six first
trying to make the Queen move here here
I play b4 b5 Bishop d7 as Queen here the
night a5 traps the Queen Queen has no
moves it's very typical bishops player
role
Knight defends upon this pawns defended
nice let's take take again
mm-hmm
okay still have to pay some slight
attention and Bishop here is coming the
King's gonna have to develop yeah now I
win the rook so I want to take and then
win the pollen
let's not pre move that I can still
legally castle I'm probably no need da I
blues castling rights I was so excited
to castle that's okay okay free Knights
play Queen g2 and then mate
yeah okay smoothie game this h.5 move
it's fun to play h5 when the pointer
plays like an early g3 doesn't always
work so well but worked there shrim
Inger
thanks for the bits welcome back oh yeah
high rated opponent higher rated than me
so I'll try and try and stick with what
I know this is a nice line queen g4 -
drawback of playing Bishop d6 to early
pawn becomes a target play Knight c3
some idea of this and nevermind Castle
queenside it's gonna say this is a kind
of a weakness
that's an interesting move play h4 and
my queen kind of got kicked
so I'm threatening to take of takes and
I win this pawn if takes I win this pawn
it's not entirely clear what black does
maybe g6 then I probably continue
developing kini 7 while I'll keep
developing I still want to take
Meeny for ephors very thematic let's
play for hey what was that tog II I'm
not sure who to root for you're the best
player win or whoever cheers more bits
made made that player away
okay let's focus because things are
getting weird I think I can take here if
night takes I have to take the center is
opening up the king is becoming more
exposed that's you
I think I'm curious to see the game but
I'm a little bit preoccupied yeah so
here Nights 94 I have three kind of
hangs mmm
you don't see what to do after Queen
takes up three idea to take analyse hey
dead man dead man welcome back how's it
going
long time no see something for 19 months
mm-hmm let's play can I take it's a very
confusing position thinking that a four
I should probably stay close to the
center though still threatening this the
king is still targets there should be
seven let's take
so expecting takes takes now f4 is a
move thing is f4 94 maybe 94 there you
59.5 I blocked the attack we're both
under attack here this move a simple
file the right time I wanna play e5 but
it's tricky
hey let's play u5 here trick Queens when
I spawn yeah I came here here I have
this ooh forgot about that takes takes
this move
u6 was hard to defend for black still
down upon no it's equal material mmm I'm
down on time I guess where does my
knight move maybe here
85 also be for Brooke c7 I just take a
lot of time to make up Oh black might
take ya
but the ending is better for me both
these phones are hit so I'll win I'll
win all the pawns Yasser will be proud
again I just have to not flag in black
might resign here I try the dirty b3
[Music]
you just have to not meet myself plenty
of time
oops
ooh I just gave everything away no well
did I just do
well that was terrible oh thank you that
was equally as terrible okay Wow
I hung two pawns Wow what was a mistake
yeah it was
I guess King b7 was a mistake man
okay almost cracked under pressure but
life goes on I'll play a walrus I'm
sticking with my aggressive repertoire
by g5 g 4 yeah I mean that's this is not
a good opening but it usually guarantees
a small time advantage and also kind of
a confusing position I'm down upon that
this pawn is kind of weak I'll have
initiative
[Music]
27 if necessary Queen D Phi might be
played well this pawn is kind of hanging
let's play let's move first I think I
could have taken this pawn actually
interesting yeah I probably just rook e8
coming I might be suffering here though
c6
I'm definitely suffering
picking d6 this is such a difficult
position why I play this opening let's
try this
maybe this move a 90 force coming man
I'm just getting hit from so many
directions no this is so bad
like weenie 7y can win another pawn by
taking takes takes I'm just trying to
like not get me anonymous promised your
thanks for the bits Jay moolah okay guys
are giving some nice moral supports in a
time of time of need what to do I'm
still so much worse here hey how's it
going
I mean maybe at six to get rid of that
pawn if I can get rid of the pawn I can
play d5 and kind of breathe in time it
actually isn't that bad
that's a scary move our t6 coefficient
t6 yeah alright let's play this move
there should be three a five what's
going on
Connect four at least
who takes takes can never mind wait
after you say me maybe this isn't so bad
hu is also hanging I'm winning pawns
kind of this bishops still locked in but
it is officer Clark bishops that's a
very good sign
there's about five ideas wow I'm not
dead
still a little bit down on time but the
positions good I was looking for meeting
ideas but doesn't quite work I'm trying
I'm trying play this move first oh that
was a bad move allowing that
[Music]
what to do to go for this
running mate oh no no no oh that's so
bad
oh I posted one earlier I'll try and
post more I was so bad
[Music]
da ha
oh the position I fought so hard The
Walrus was almost resurrected okay good
game well played
oh it's a it's a very close battle for
first oh there's three people including
me with 32 there's 34 minutes left
I didn't resign because I had one pass
pawn I was almost about to perform a
miracle yeah it didn't quite work I'll
play this move there's a trap 97 takes
off seven hmm play Bishop me too it's
gonna be a positional and game um I
probably have to play off or not the
move I wanted to play okay Bishop f2
and before looks nice c5 will come at
some points let's play you takin c5 this
move hmm I should win the pawn a 5-iron
pass on
I'm trying to figure out the best
approach here and go for this
that's tricky
I mean this looks passive but the idea
is to control d1 now e4 trying to fight
for the D file you maybe rook on d6 at
some points each three I mean I'm
dreaming of getting the bishop in Wow g5
okay so my dream might actually come
true takes here King moves and then this
and this blocks not budging
ooh black budged okay there's about six
coming dreams can come true if you
believe hard enough all right hey first
place let's go I have to just maintain
and continue to avoid losing that's a
nice game it was a weird opening I was
maybe worse at some point but after I
won the pawn I was better
let's not berserk I'll fight you for
this game I'll mix it up a little bit
okay play this line reverse Stafford
gambit
Oh opponent knows what to do um God this
is what I play what do I do here I have
to take and play vision t3 no lets
castle
yeah castling I think is a trickiest
move trying to stay with a reversed
after gambit it's been a while since
I've looked at this from the white side
smooth can I take in rookie one d 64
okay so I'll take d4 anyway
okay so we have some position put the
bishop there there's a g4 expected okay
so now the bishop can't really develop
actively Queen b6 rook b1 takes bishop
here
Bishop e5 in the typical maneuver is 92
which might be hard to play after this
f4 but then Queen b6 maybe that's okay
Queen b6 King h2 takes Queen d2 double
threat of rook e1 and f5
[Music]
that fire was a threat anyway ooh it's
very tempting here very tempting I'm
gonna hold off just quiet move
okay now if I want to play f5 now would
be the time yeah let's do it
I have a dream I have a dream of getting
a night to have six okay let's take with
pawn oh wait oh I just messed up
I forgot the bish yeah the bishop was
defending I take I lose the rook that's
sad
my dream can still maybe come true
I'm down a pawn here f6 my calm
[Music]
yeah I'm much worse and down on time not
a good combo
oh thanks dougie
Oh tog II with the sad bits how'd you do
tally you don't look happy
yeah this is not a happy position for me
Brooke honey III wasn't not a good
square maybe okay maybe it's still okay
is the Bishop's pinned and the bishop
obstructs both our looks from attacking
each other's Queens g4g for Queen d2
rookie - it's just a mess I'm expecting
the Queen to move
I take whatever makes you happy okay not
enough for ideas interesting this is not
comfortable don't wait too much time
there - we're kind of in a deadlock
which means it's time to push pawns
that's a good move or is it oh I'm
winning a queen that was not a good move
Wow coming back let's go up a queen now
idea this I turned her around really
quickly that's life
that's a fork okay time to take pawns
okay so I said what did I say was a good
move
I said Bishop before was a good move but
that was probably just a blunder a
tricky position with especially with a
nice light was a good piece on that for
even though it was pinned for part of
the time
hmm still some catching up to do I think
I played the walrus earlier let's play
something a little bit more solid
yeah qgd play the line with a six this
is kind of my pet line and there's a
pretty simple plan in this position 9 f8
to g6 the e5 I can play Knight g4
oh I supposed to play c6 maybe not just
have to keep the pawn defended
don't really want to trade probably
gonna have to at some point bishop they
can only move back I'll take with pawn
Oh weights uh you know it's doing the
minority attack its Queen b6 some idea
of just unraveling why do I scream so
late because candidates are coming up
mmm do I see tog II keep working talkie
[Music]
its play play this move yeah I'm trying
to change my sleep schedule saw the
awake during like candidates adjusting
to to rush in time let's play play this
move interesting some idea of doing
something with the night yeah now that
night's a bit restricted should probably
defend the pawn its weakening the
squares a long-term weakness 36 I take
the g5 there is hmm this is difficult
there's this smooth this crazy move
maybe I'll play this smooth not sure for
the accomplish as much Oh saben plus 500
so you're not playing the tournament I
see uh-huh okay I want to get to c4c
let's go for this so everything's
defended now there's no we're not f5
because the Queen's not on d3 players of
all abilities here what to do there's
night 98 queen g4 is coming I'll allow
it
just play Queen e7 just being safe like
a five
[Music]
not sure if this is strong or delicate
it's gonna maneuver here at some point
okay I'm maneuvering with the rook have
this move hmm not what I wanted
play this move it's a very tricky
position that's a good move in your time
oh dear yeah I'm about to get smashed
ah it's gonna be another loss okay
I was rough I just got outplayed white
played really well
he's a nice position aligned so that
really hurt my chances I have to berserk
out probably probably to try and win the
tournament so let's try my best play
abou the past
ah hadn't heard that one in a while
let's play my vision before that was one
of my first emotes actually okay so the
goal is to prevent light from castling
by seizing initiative Bishop takes I
allow this let's go for this it's a
sharp line Queen me three out of this
move Queen e7
hmm let's take first yeah I wanted to
take weather issue without seven
you know it's still I didn't want to
open that file
okay White's insisting yeah I think yeah
there's no 95
actually there is Wow
I think Knight g5 could have just been
winning that's a delicate position again
you know I grabbed a pawn but things are
kind of scattered I mean all my pieces
are on like undesirable squares this is
a huge target I'm hoping that I can
stabilize this looks so weakening good
thing I'm controlling all these squares
though
yeah some alignments like the Queen and
rook are now talking to each other
Wow what does this move yeah
rooks move backwards that's a tricky
move though so I'm up in lights time is
good I need to get in as many games as
possible in the remaining time oh that's
some really bad move
those are really bad move it's still
gonna be a fight
and I still like my chances but it's
unacceptable blunder
yeah we have a rock ending just gave
away at night look after you I can check
and move back so I think it waits in a
bit of a pickle it takes I do this and
then I'm just winning yeah I'm probably
just winning regardless let's do this
first
okay
39 points so a lot not to catch up I
need to rely on someone ahead of me
losing oh why didn't I take with her
Brooke first I assume you're referring
to Rock cakes III early on there are
issues with that seven I think it just
it looks wrong a type of thing you can
probably analyze working in f4 okay
let's play aggressively
some people play E form trick yeah
playing one of these people I should see
for a slightly new move this is a Falk
beer counter gambit it's uh can be a fun
opening
looking for ways to maximize my my
initiative in Queenie seven
I take now
I took here first and tricky why wants
to just trot my bishop
Wow
what's going on
okay I was looking for like Queen h4
tactics I didn't see anything
that's a good move let's castle
I wanna get a Realty Yates Wow
you know it's flying in a very
cold-blooded fashion I have 33 seconds
and as I desert
okay some progress and then for incoming
idea of 95 also each three is a bit the
tender let's play and play the smooth
attacking the Queen I wanna play III the
right moment
nevermind
you can just say twice very difficult to
play with so little time
get some endgame
there we go
let's go okay well the game and that was
a confusing game I got it done
six points all the first have to keep
his working oh so much adrenaline ten
minutes left should be enough time for
least jooheon's
first place the first place still
playing let's play e4 to go all out with
upon Jionni maybe maybe not a
complicated position
[Music]
opponents will perplex I mean attacking
the pond there's so many different ways
to defend you can even counter-attack
always play g5
hey it's a sub neon bullfrogs thanks for
subbing okay so blocks playing a black
lion pace for slowing down b5 Wow
interesting
that's taken Bishop d3 Oh die plunder
no I didn't plunder a 5 out of Bishop c4
check upon's playing while though
yeah that may have been like some
opening prep blissed-out so quickly
I've put the bishop here g5 Wow
I'm losing the pawn but it takes I win
the Queen meanwhile I want to play this
smooth black can't develop let's play Oh
wants to win the pawn
okay so let's counter-attack the g5
pawned
there's no work ta no h6 and I want to
play Bishop c3 again takes Bishop c3
buzu g6 hopefully queen 86
I want to make this work probably gonna
have to optimize my rook it's a nice
black cap blockade the pawn it's a
problem with you six a box my bishop I
mean there's a line here here it takes
this was looking pretty good is here
here and then rook d7
upon time the opponent has taken a lot
of time to scheme Hey
une Astro continuing the sub gifts you
got from a KD 707 thanks so much
appreciate that it's very difficult
position for black as I'm controlling so
many squares in the territory patrolling
almost all the squares in Black's
territory except C 6 and this is so hard
to stop
so I think box I'm just gonna flag pay
this in this oh there's a nice windmill
possibility Queen g7 maybe kind of I
don't know or just made into trying to
take in meat and the Queen okay that was
a nice game took down the Black Lion
mm-hmm it's gonna be close finish yeah
those bishops were nice ooh
okay let's dessert that's good okay this
game will finish before the trim in
hands Oh free pawn that's nice
the Queen's tied down like the g7 pawn
we need five I love that the Brooke
straps woo woo yeah I was a great
opening just rook let's play Bishop c4
[Music]
have to stay focused
let's defend c2 Queen g5 I just want to
prompt resignation meets GU yeah there
we go let's go that was the best
possible scenario like beating beating a
high rate player like that like so
quickly okay so I'm back in first Wow
hopefully I have time for one more game
crunch master could pass me so I'm gonna
have to win and have to win this game
[Music]
London time
I have to stay focused
uh-huh yeah you get drawn in let's play
this move a box actually playing a
decent line here Queen B 693 Wow
it's taken Bishop e5
hmmm this would be five Queenie two
interesting the Queenie - anyway
did this move so fancy move idea in ig6
or queen h5 queen e7 maybe just King f1
interesting like g6 it's so fancy I just
want to win something the Queen e7 at
some point to make here maybe 27 doesn't
quite work so I'll take first the light
controls the g7 or Queen e2 immense yes
like vision about seven Queen e2
thinking f7 expected the king f7 I have
Queen h5 it's still tricky castle
oh did I blunder I think I kinda
blundered but maybe not there's about
five I have Bishop d3 thankfully I'm 97
97
let's take in than 97 I'll fork Queen
takes I would fork more things I want to
bring the rook from each seven to a fork
[Music]
hmm okay that was quick
because Queen a6 is now hard to stop
yeah crunch master passed me so I need
to win this game into this also ideas
like a for safety first
I'm making loops and also attacking
Queen f1 I hope one's gonna try the
Carlson idea oh maybe not Oh forgot
about that move ooh
I messed up though I really messed up
Wow
oh wow oh that's so bad I might not win
this and this move
she's not what I wanted
died wind did I did I make it yes
my opponent flagged right before the
turn intended that was the closest call
ever Wow
for the finish I need it
wow that was so close someone clip it oh
man I really almost messed that up
completely winning but McNichol uh
thanks for the bass wow what a game all
this game I've I thought it was
completely winning like here this is a
very tricky move I thought my point was
just giving up and was gonna try this so
we might clean I forgot my rook was
hanging yeah the thing about the time
scrambled too is that sometimes there's
more lag when when we're like both pre
moving but yeah the leech our server was
quick enough for for me to get in a
dirty flag see ghost thanks for the gift
in slow yeah okay this will go on
YouTube hello to YouTube yeah thanks
people on YouTube for watching thanks
people on twitch for watching appreciate
the viewership was so much nervousness
in adrenaline